when I'm making a big decision or my
husband and I are making a big kind of
Life decision he will always say to me
we don't make choices out of fear we you
and me we are not going to make these
choices out of fear and I think that
that's something that I've did a really
good job of and he and I have done a
really good job of as this kind of team
is even when we are afraid or things get
hard we are able to kind of transcend
that and and not make big decisions
based on fear and basing them instead on
on what joy and love and optimism and
possibility we're not risk averse and
that's probably to a fault sometimes our
choices have not worked out but in the
grand scheme of things we're living this
you know really Purpose Driven
fulfilling life it's such an exciting
fulfilling way to live and I think that
I feel so alive in the things that I
pursue even though it's not always easy